do you think you could be a successful
husband and father or do you know deep
down inside i love my career i'm married
to my career that's all i want is to be
a good husband and a father like that to
me is
them
that really is what i want and now that
i have fulfilled a lot of things in my
career
that i feel comfortable with i can
safely say that i don't know if i could
have said that before but now i'm like i
also see
my sister right and i see how her life
her family her her marriage has just
deepened her work
i think there comes a point where
you you go
you either start getting more shallow or
you start getting more deep right in
your work and i think you have to
incorporate those things into your life
in order for that to happen i think
you're going to get married i did some
research i was looking at pictures of
your girlfriend i watched you guys and
you're you know you don't bring just
anybody anywhere you're one of those
guys you keep the relationships on the
down low you're out there man i mean now
i see you're in love i love her so much
and she's just such a such a good person
so i yes i mean
my family's close like the other night
my sister premiered her movie she wrote
and directed at the new york film
festival she wanted to be out there
supporting my sister and you know my
sister grabbed grabbed her and pulled
her on that red carpet which i think
neither of us are really inclined to you
know
go on even me
and
to be there to support my sister was
what we were there to do and i was like
oh yeah it's family it's family